[Applause]
[Music]
heaven can't exist without help
it's not two worlds it's one
[Music]
the Berlin radio choir in cooperation
with the American theater director and
visual artist Robert Wilson brings
Luther and Bach to the stage Luther
dancing with the gods is a production
based on Martin Luther's writings and
his biblical translation thoughtful
Luther was always plagued by incredible
anxiety from the time when he first
believed that makes it so relevant for
us because we also live in a period when
everybody is plagued by anxiety and
feels threatened he created a new idea
in which he believed that faith and
trust in Jesus Christ and the Word of
God would help him find something to
rely on it was so fitting office on
Fatone I think that's a very
contemporary issue many people are
searching today for somebody or
something they can still trust do you
want of us come on a robe Noire Fatone
Robert Wilson trusts his images Luther
trusted language and translated the
Bible from Greek into German the
production plays with Luther's language
his translations and writings some of
the texts are recited in the original
Greek by the actress Lydia corny odo who
is currently the Greek culture minister
the entire creative team is
international notes a song not by for me
I've been involved in developing the
project from the start that's why we
call ourselves the creative team because
we work together and each person
contributes ideas which are then
developed all of course I wouldn't eat
to the basic idea that Bob had and what
the ideas inspiring him dances are
refined food the old master of images is
still full of inspiration and the ideas
are perfected step by step for Wilson
every movement every posture has to be
just right
[Music]
basically it's an enormous jigsaw puzzle
did Robert Wilson is constructing and
all of my works I grabbed them or put
them together mathematically so I can
see the total picture quickly and later
we can fill in for more content a
crucial element is the lighting to me
light is the most essential element in
theater in architecture Albert Einstein
said light is the measure of all things
and without life there's no space
[Music]
the whole auditorium becomes a stage
[Music]
shaft he creates works of art in which
people mentor talented people move and
speak or sing well and specializing our
others first
but everything else light sounds props
stage set whether it's painted on the
floor on the ceiling or roundabout
regardless everything is supposed to
come together that's how he rehearses to
some come
[Music]
I've been working 50 years in the
theater I've never once ever and 50
years told someone what to think or have
I put an interpretation on the work its
interpretations for the public maybe for
philosophers we're gonna think about
things in time
[Music]
[Music]
behind stage is what you might call the
laboratory where the singers and actors
are dressed and paid up to become the
figures that Robert Wilson and his team
have imagined
when some actors are not able to attend
all of the rehearsals their doubles have
to appear in full costume this for
instance is lydia corny order whose
double theater is neither psychological
nor naturalistic instead it finds signs
and abstract expression for particular
experiences developments feelings
installations and events it never tries
to depict a naturalistic or
psychological image of the figure the
question is rather what strength did
this person this historical figure have
what motivated him what emotions areas
developments of human society did he
influence what influence did he have on
the individual I'm Fred but something
changed when Luther refused to retract
his theses he was condemned by the Pope
and eventually banished here Rome's
accusations and Luther's defense at the
Council of forms are symbolized as a row
a cacophony of contradictory voices
[Music]
200 years later johann sebastian bach
set the Reformers texts to music
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
clobbered us there for Matt Sean's good
I think the Reformation plays a
subordinate role main focus here is
Luther but I think the religious aspects
are well represented by the motet seeing
a lot of Christian texts spiritual works
there the focus is on religion more than
in the scenes which are interspersed
hundred-eyed stand-in in the-- Nandita
tuition laughing
[Music]
the singing and acting are rehearsed
again and again until they coalesce the
Protestant Corral's are supplemented by
20th century compositions Steve Reich's
clapping music for instance the singers
all wear their gloves at rehearsals
I mentioned Sheila good minds um we've
done a lot of our productions with
choruses but I have to say it's not the
radio choir stock-in-trade
this is an exception for them it's not
their first time but it's not what they
usually do so go around once that's like
the first appearance then of course all
in black it was all NASA so fee and
photo home certainly the space is very
interesting one of course the figure of
Luther is as well but this space is very
interesting because it isn't a
conventional theatre Pattillo this is
not picture frame theatre it's a very
special architecture it was clear from
the start that it would be staged here
so the whole concept was developed with
this in mind they are asking for monitor
the basic idea is an amphitheater that
brought the Greek element into the
production on the sub so one thing led
to another one and agent we could
Wilson and the choir chose this space
deliberately for its unusual shape but
also for its superb acoustics the Pierre
Boulez Hall opened in the spring of 2017
designed by Franco Gehry and built at
the back of the Deutsche OPA one of
Berlin's three opera houses it's the
home turf of Daniel Barenboim sayyid
Academy
the Berlin radio choir is used to
performing in unusual venues with
interdisciplinary projects in New York
Tokyo and other cultural capitals it's
earned itself an international
reputation the singers are used to
performing with large orchestras and
famous conductors Tigers are shy and
sometimes it's exhausting it demands
incredible concentration and it is very
new for us because we aren't an opera
chorus row radio choir that means our
forte is concert performance we normally
stand behind the orchestra open our
scores sing and that's it sing and fun
this is performing especially with the
director like Bob Wilson is an enormous
challenge for all of us
[Music]
sensitivity is required all around
[Music]
which biased us for Nicholas and
sagansky no vice bus Bob Wilson Weston I
know that Nicola Panza understands
exactly what Bob Wilson wants she has a
fantastic way of rehearsing with us
because she radiates an incredible calm
even when we have to repeat some
movement ten times because for instance
the lighting wasn't correct we start to
lose patience but she remains absolutely
calm she talks to us very quietly and
takes us through the movements I think
she knows exactly what the result is
supposed to be I'm saying built
[Music]
on opening night this scene is darker
and more subdued than originally planned
in rehearsal it looked like this the
singers were using white balls and the
cow cadaver was red
[Music]
overnight red and white became black and
two wooden slats that had previously
been used disappeared one fazool minor
and as they are sure in a mission to ha
always trying to achieve a good mix
you're not supposed to hear individual
voices but here were more in the realm
of musical theatre or you could even
call it opera in which individuality is
a bit more important the image shown and
disinvesting of ed Iceland ours to cover
his principal conductor and artistic
director of the Berlin radio choir in
August 2015 because this stage is
circular he's assisted by a co conductor
Benjamin gutsy
[Music]
as yet in Lisa for Shalom finish there
into a Sun disease does what I find so
interesting about this production is
that Wilson has made a very personal
selection of texts by Luther and of
images from contemporary paintings on
Maidan satisfied conditions he made and
so I see the invitation to read and
understand more about the period that
side when Wilson quotes from the Book of
Revelations he transports us into the
apocalyptic visions of the first
Christian century what really good I'm
not religious so Luther doesn't mean
anything to me in that context but he
means a lot to me as the man to whom
together with others we owe the modern
German language did your daughter's
father for done also the poetry Z we owe
him the mystique of German we have a
beautiful language
[Music]
[Music]
Wilson's strict choreography even in
case of the innocent child is
reminiscent of the strict choreography
of a liturgy
[Music]
this is not a church it's a concert hall
and maybe what I have is is a spiritual
feeling maybe the light is and juice is
something that's spiritual but yeah I
hope it's not a religious service
religion has no place in the theater a
key scene is Luther's death
Wilson clearly defines the arrangement
of the death bed in particular the
arrangement of the blanket and the
precisely determined folding of the
sheet have to be practiced by the
assistance so that it looks exactly the
same at each performance
[Music]
he markings all very fond of him because
he is such a loving worker but he's not
sloppy
he is absolutely precise I think
precision and not arbitrariness is an
aspect of every form of art when
performed this death scene takes 12
minutes it begins with a quotation from
Luther about children their innocence
joy and purity
[Laughter]
[Music]
Martin Luther for me is a point in time
and you have different points in
different eras and which change happens
and so I see it was something more
abstractly it said it's a point in time
where things are changed the stylized
housewife in the final scene seems to
point to Luther's wife Catarina
[Music]
vicen God the Saturday Felicita baguette
business and that's why sergeant bye-bye
capsule embassy Nazca Peru design at the
feeling that it's a typically American
characteristic adding a bit of
razzmatazz I think Bob Wilson wanted to
slip in a bit of that style and he
pulled it off
actually that isn't the end for in a
Robert Wilson production even the
curtain call is choreographed
you